COMMITTEE FOR THIRSTY AUGUST
NINETEENTH IS HEREBY CALLED
ORDER. PLEASE BE ADVISED THAT
AUDIO AND VIDEO RECORDING OF
TODAY'S PROCEED HAS BEEN MADE
AND HAS ALSO BEEN TELEVISED
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC ATTENDED
THIS HEARING MUST WEAR A MASK
AT ALL TIMES AND COMPLY WITH
GUIDANCE ON PHYSICAL
DISTANCING. ATTENDEES MUST ALSO
REFRAIN FROM CONDUCT THAT
DISRUPTS DISTURBS OR OTHERWISE
IMPEDES THE ORDERLY CONDUCT
THIS HEARING VIOLATIONS OF
THESE RULES MAY SUBJECT
ENVISIONED FOR MOBILE OR OTHER
ENFORCEMENT PROCESS. ON MR
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
COOLEY HERE CUNNINGHAM HERE
BENNETT HERE FLORA GIPSON HERE
LEE HERE MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS
YOUR RAMOS HERE RUBIO HERE
VEHICLES LAW. WEBER FLORA.
THEIR CAR- WE HAVE A QUORUM WE
HAVE A PROPOSED CONSENT AGENDA.
THANK OF HI MISTER CHAIRS
BUCKLEY REQUEST TO REMOVE THE
FOLLOWING ITEMS FROM CONSENT
FIRST TO BE THE REFERRAL OF SB
THREE THIRTY WHICH I BELIEVE
SHOULD BE DOUBLE REFERRED TO
HIGHER EDUCATION- IN ADDITION
ITEM NINETEEN WHICH IS THE
WAIVER JOINT RULE SIXTY ONE A
AND FINALLY ITEM EIGHTEEN.
WHICH HAS AN URGENCY REQUEST A
REQUEST WITHOUT SEPARATELY ON
THESE THREE MATTERS THANK YOU
OKAY WE WILL- ADJUSTED CHEN
ACCORDINGLY SO. IS OUR MOTION
ON THE REMAINDER OF THE CONSENT
AGENDA. MOVERS GIPSON SIDE OF
AYE MR MATTIS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MR SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL COOLEY. AYE COOLEY AYE
CUNNINGHAM. CUNNINGHAM I.
BENNETT. BENNETT HI FLORA FLOOR
AYE GIPSON AYE GIPSON HIGHLY.
THE AYE MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN AYE MATHIS. MATHIS
AYE RAMOS. RAMOS I RUBIO. RUBIO
FIVE YOU COULD WHAT WEBER.
WEBER HI MOTION PASSED THAT OF
PASS ON TURNING NOW IS OUR
EMOTIONAL ITEM NUMBER EIGHTEEN
THE URGENCY BECAUSE REQUEST FOR
SB SIXTY BY MISTER GLAZER. R.
MOVER MISTER GIPSON SECONDED BY
MISTER BENNETT OF MR SURFER
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON THAT
ITEM COOLEY AYE COOLEY AYE
CUNNINGHAM. CUNNINGHAM AYE
BENNETT. BENNETT HI FLORA LAURA
HI GIPSON GIPSON HIGHLY THE AYE
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN AYE
MATHIS NO MATHIS NOTE RAMOS
RAMOS I RUBIO RUBIO IDEA PUT
WHAT WEBER. WEBER I AM MOST
IMPASSES THAT MOTION IS PASSED
OF FINALLY IS OUR MOTION ON THE
REFERRAL OF SB THREE THIRTY
DHIRAJ SO TO THE HOUSING
COMMITTEE VELLUM COMMITTEE AND
ITEM NUMBER NINETEEN THE JUNGLE
SIXTY ONE A WAIVER TO ALLOW THE
BILL TO BE HEARD BY. HCD
COMMITTEE A MOVER MISTER GIPSON
SECONDED BY MR LEE HONEST
SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
COOLEY AYE COOLEY AYE
CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM KNOW
BENNETT. VENETI FLORA FLORA NO
GIPSON. GIPSON HIGHLY MAY I
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN AYE
MATHIS MATHIS NO RAMOS. RAMOS I
RUBIO. RUBIO IV APPROVED LAW
WEBER. WEBER HI MOTION PASSES
ARE THAT MOTION IS PASSED I
THANK YOU ALL FOR JOINING ME
THIS COMMITTEE IS ADJOURNED.